- [Man] It's something that
I see this with a lot of people
this is what I do but they
hold themselves back.
- [Gary] It's your accent,
it's your this.
It's 'cause your mom told
you weren't good enough.
There's so many things.
What's your alternative?
We've all got our stuff.
And I think that, I think
the quicker you realize yes
I may have more self-confidence
than you but you may have
things that I don't.
I just don't spend any time
thinking what all of you have
more than me.
I just focus on honing what I
have more than you 24/7/365.
I think that what's holding you
back is what you think other
people are going
to say about it.
The people that are scared
to fail stay within a comfort
zone and can only
hit a certain level.
Most of you are not
scared to fail for yourself.
You're scared to fail and
then somebody else that you
care about is judging you.
I just don't give a shit what my
parents or wife or kids think.
My friends, I'm telling
you something right now,
I'm desperately excited to
fail in front of you.
Because A, I don't really give a
fuck what you think and
B, I'm gonna learn from it and
C, battle scars are attractive.
(light music)